in the Greek Port City of Volos cars are
washed away like bits of debris heavy
rainfall and floods are battering a
region emerging from the European
Union's largest wildfires on record
extreme weather patterns the Greek Prime
Minister says have become the norm
I think everyone realizes there are
certain weather phenomena that are
beyond our capacity to handle no matter
how many flood prevention tools we have
when an unprecedented volume of water
falls which happens everywhere in the
world we will unfortunately have
flooding I am hoping the meteorologists
aren't right but we know we'll be facing
some difficult hours ahead
emergency services are spread thin and
overwhelmed survivors are becoming
desperate
we call the fire department the
municipality the prefecture there is no
one cars have already been Swift into
the sea we will mourn the dead we have
been talking to emergency services and
the fire departments since morning and
there's complete indifference people
with small children are at risk they are
asking for help
similar scenes in neighboring Bulgaria
the black region normally a hub for
tourists now an inhospitable disaster
Zone
vast areas are in a state of emergency
and evacuations are underway hampered by
damaged Bridges and closed roads the
resort town of sarovo was hardest hit
and with predictions of more rain people
are moving to Higher Ground
in turkey at least two people were
washed away when flood waters swept
through a camping site in the Northwest
other holiday makers are missing search
and rescue operations are underway in
Istanbul Heavy Rain flooded streets and
homes in at least two suburbs the
disaster management agency says more
storms are predicted in parts of the
country and has issued warnings for
flash floods lightning and strong winds
forecasters say a heat Dome over Europe
is causing high temperatures and
resulting in extreme weather
phenomena that can last for days weeks
even months this they say could become
one of the worst floods in Europe in
recorded history
Al Jazeera
make sure to subscribe to our channel to
get the latest news from Al Jazeera